y luego se parten.
Así que nuestras metáforas equiparan la experiencia de amar a alguien
a la violencia o la enfermedad extrema.
(Risas)
Lo hacen.
Y nos posicionan como las víctimas
de circunstancias imprevistas y totalmente inevitables.
Mi favorito de estas es "smitten",
que es el participio pasado de la palabra "smite", golpear.
Y si buscan esta palabra en el diccionario...
(Risas)
verán que se puede definir como "aflicción grave",
y, "estar muy enamorado".
Suelo asociar la palabra "smite" a un contexto muy particular,
el Antiguo Testamento.
En el Libro del Éxodo solo, hay 16 referencias a "smiting",
que es la palabra que usa la Biblia para la venganza de un Dios enojado.
(Risas)
Usamos la misma palabra para hablar del amor
que para explicar una plaga de langostas.
(Risas)
¿Cierto?
Entonces, ¿cómo sucedió esto?
¿Cómo llegamos a asociar el amor a un gran dolor y sufrimiento?
Y ¿por qué hablamos de esta experiencia ostensiblemente buena
como si fuéramos víctimas?
Estas son preguntas difíciles,
pero tengo algunas teorías.
Y para analizarlo,
quiero enfocarme en una metáfora en particular
que es la idea de amor como locura.
Cuando empecé a investigar el amor romántico,
encontré estas locas metáforas en todas partes.
La historia de la cultura occidental
está llena de lenguaje que equipara amor a enfermedad mental.
Estos son solo algunos ejemplos.
William Shakespeare,
"el amor es pura locura"
de "Como les guste".
Friedrich Nietzsche,
"siempre hay una locura en el amor".
"Me observa, me mira tan locamente enamorado",
(Risas)
de la gran filósofa, Beyoncé Knowles.
Me enamoré por primera vez a los 20 años,
y fue una relación bastante turbulenta desde el principio.
Fue de larga distancia durante el primer par de años,
así que para mí eso significaba altos muy altos y bajos muy bajos.
Puedo recordar un momento en particular.
Estaba sentada en una cama en un albergue en América del Sur,
y estaba viendo a la persona que amaba salir por la puerta.
Y ya era tarde,
era casi medianoche,
habíamos discutido durante la cena,
y cuando llegamos a nuestra habitación,
metió sus cosas en la bolsa y salió disparado.
Aunque ya no puedo recordar de qué se trataba esa pelea,
recuerdo muy claramente cómo me sentí viéndolo salir.
Yo tenía 22 años, era mi primera vez en el mundo en desarrollado,
y estaba totalmente sola.
Tuve otra semana hasta mi vuelo a casa,
y sabía el nombre de la ciudad en la que estaba,
y el de la ciudad a la que debía llegar para tomar el vuelo,
pero no tenía ni idea de cómo moverme.
No tenía guía y tenía muy poco dinero,
y no hablaba español.
Alguien más aventurero que yo
podría haber visto esto como un momento de oportunidad,
pero simplemente me congelé.
Solo me senté allí.
Y luego me eché a llorar.
Pero a pesar de mi pánico,
una pequeña voz en mi cabeza pensó:
"Guau, eso fue dramático.
Realmente esto del amor se me da bien".
(Risas)
Porque alguna parte de mí quería sentirse miserable en el amor.
Y suena tan extraño para mí ahora, pero a los 22,
anhelaba tener experiencias dramáticas.
En ese momento, fui irracional y estaba furiosa y devastada,
y de manera bastante rara
pensé que esto de algún modo legitimó los sentimientos que tenía
para el tipo que acababa de dejarme.
Creo que en cierta forma quería sentirme un poco loca,
porque pensé que el amor funcionaba así.
Esto realmente no debería sorprender
considerando que, según Wikipedia,
hay ocho películas,
14 canciones,
dos álbumes y una novela con el título "Crazy Love".
Alrededor de media hora más tarde, regresó a nuestra habitación.
Hicimos las paces.
Pasamos otra semana prácticamente felices viajando juntos.
Y luego, cuando llegué a casa,
pensé: "Fue terrible y genial.
Esto debe ser un verdadero romance".
Esperaba enloquecer con mi primer amor,
y, por supuesto, cumplió esa expectativa muy bien.
Pero amar a alguien así
- como si todo mi bienestar dependiera de que fuera recíproco -
no era muy bueno para mí,
ni para él.
Pero sospecho que esta experiencia de amor no es tan inusual.
Casi todos nos sentimos un poco locos en la primera etapa del amor romántico.
De hecho, hay investigaciones que confirman que esto es algo normal,
porque, neuroquímicamente hablando,
amor romántico y enfermedad mental no se distinguen tan fácilmente.
Esto es cierto.
Este estudio de 1999 mediante análisis de sangre
confirmó que los niveles de serotonina del recién enamorado
son muy parecidos a los niveles de serotonina
de personas a las que se diagnosticó un trastorno obsesivo-compulsivo.
(Risas)
Sí, y bajos niveles de serotonina
también están asociados al trastorno afectivo estacional
y la depresión.
Así que hay alguna evidencia
de que el amor está asociado a cambios en el estado de ánimo y el comportamiento.
Y hay otros estudios que confirman que
casi todas las relaciones comienzan así.
Los investigadores creen que los bajos niveles de serotonina
se relacionan con el pensamiento obsesivo sobre el tema del amor,
que es como esta sensación de que alguien ha acampado en tu cerebro.
Y la mayoría nos sentimos así al enamorarnos por primera vez.
Pero la buena noticia es que no siempre dura mucho tiempo;
por lo general de unos pocos meses a un par de años.
Cuando volví de mi viaje por América del Sur,
pasé mucho tiempo sola en mi habitación,
comprobando mi email,
desesperada por oír del tipo que amaba.
Decidí que si mis amigos no podían entender mi dolorosa aflicción,
entonces no necesitaba su amistad.
Así que dejé de salir con la mayoría de ellos.
Y fue probablemente el año más infeliz de mi vida.
Pero creo que me sentí como que era mi trabajo ser miserable,
porque si podía ser miserable,
demostraría cuánto lo amaba.
Y si podía demostrarlo,
tendríamos que terminar juntos.
Esta es la verdadera locura,
porque no hay ninguna regla cósmica
que diga que un gran sufrimiento equivale a una gran recompensa,
pero hablamos de amor como si esto fuera cierto.
Nuestras experiencias de amor son biológicas y culturales.
Nuestra biología nos dice que el amor es bueno
activando estos circuitos de recompensa en el cerebro,
y nos dice que el amor es doloroso cuando, después de una pelea o ruptura,
la recompensa neuroquímica se retira.
Y de hecho - y tal vez han oído esto -
neuroquímicamente hablando,
pasar por una ruptura es como pasar por la desintoxicación de cocaína,
que encuentro tranquilizador.
(Risas)
Y entonces nuestra cultura usa el lenguaje
para formar y reforzar estas ideas sobre el amor.
En este caso, estamos hablando de metáforas sobre el dolor
y la adicción y la locura.
Es un ciclo de retroalimentación interesante.
El amor es poderoso y a veces doloroso,
y lo expresamos en nuestras palabras e historias,
pero luego nuestras palabras e historias nos llevan
a esperar que el amor sea poderoso y doloroso.
Lo interesante para mí es que todo esto sucede
en una cultura que valora la monogamia de por vida.
Parece que lo queremos en ambos sentidos:
queremos que el amor sea una locura,
y que dure toda una vida.
Eso suena terrible.
(Risas)
Para conciliar esto,
necesitamos cambiar nuestra cultura o cambiar nuestras expectativas.
Entonces, imaginen si fuéramos todos menos pasivos en el amor.
Si fuéramos más asertivos, más abiertos, más generosos
y en vez de enamorarnos,
nos abriéramos al amor.
Sé que esto es pedir mucho,
pero en realidad no soy la primera persona que sugiere esto.
En su libro "Metáforas por las que vivimos", los lingüistas
Mark Johnson y George Lakoff sugieren una solución muy interesante
a este dilema,
que es cambiar nuestras metáforas.
Argumentan que las metáforas dan forma a la manera de experimentar el mundo.
Y que incluso pueden actuar como una guía para acciones futuras,
como profecías autocumplidas.
Johnson y Lakoff sugieren una nueva metáfora para el amor:
el amor como obra de arte colaborativa.
Realmente me gusta esta forma de pensar el amor.
Los lingüistas hablan de metáforas como que tienen implicaciones,
que es esencialmente una forma de considerar todas las implicaciones,
o ideas contenidas dentro de una metáfora dada.
Johnson y Lakoff hablan de todo
lo que implica la colaboración en una obra de arte:
esfuerzo, compromiso, paciencia, objetivos compartidos.
Estas ideas se alinean bien con nuestra inversión cultural
en el compromiso romántico a largo plazo,
pero también funcionan bien para otros tipos de relaciones
- a corto plazo, casual, poliamorosa, no monógama, asexual -
porque esta metáfora trae ideas mucho más complejas
a la experiencia de amar a alguien.
Así que si el amor es una obra de arte colaborativa,
entonces el amor es una experiencia estética.
El amor es impredecible,
el amor es creativo,
el amor requiere comunicación y disciplina,
es frustrante y emocionalmente exigente.
Y el amor implica alegría y dolor.
En última instancia, cada experiencia de amor es diferente.
Cuando era más joven,
nunca se me ocurrió que se me permitiera exigir más del amor,
que no tenía que aceptar simplemente cualquier amor ofrecido.
Cuando Julieta de 14 años conoce...
o, cuando Julieta de 14 años no puede estar con Romeo,
a quien conoció hace cuatro días,
ella no se siente decepcionada o angustiada.
¿Dónde está?
Ella quiere morir.
¿Cierto?
Y a modo de repaso, en este punto de la obra,
acto tres de cinco,
Romeo no está muerto.
Está vivo,
está sano,
acaba de ser desterrado de la ciudad.
Entiendo que la Verona del s. XVI difiere de la América del Norte contemporánea,
y sin embargo cuando leí esta obra por primera vez,
también a los 14 años,
el sufrimiento de Julieta tenía sentido para mí.
Replantearse el amor como algo que voy a crear con alguien que admiro,
en lugar de algo que me pasa a mí
sin mi control o consentimiento,
es empoderamiento.
Todavía es difícil.
El amor es algo loco y abrumador algunos días,
y cuando me siento realmente frustrada,
tengo que recordarme a mí misma:
mi trabajo en esta relación es hablar con mi pareja
sobre lo que quiero que hagamos juntos.
Esto tampoco es fácil.
Pero es mucho mejor que la alternativa,
que es lo que parece una locura.
Esta versión del amor no implica ganar o perder el afecto de alguien.
En su lugar, requiere confiar en la pareja
y hablar cuando confiar parece difícil,
algo que suena muy simple,
pero es un acto revolucionario, radical.
Esto se debe a que uno debe dejar de pensar en uno mismo
y en lo que gana o pierde en la relación,
y debe empezar a pensar qué tiene para ofrecer.
Esta versión del amor nos permite decir cosas como:
"No somos muy buenos colaboradores. Tal vez esto no es para nosotros".
O, "Esa relación fue más corta de lo que había planeado,
pero fue algo hermoso".
Lo bello de la obra de arte colaborativa
es que no se va a pintar o dibujar o esculpir a sí misma.
Esta versión del amor nos permite decidir su aspecto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)